nouvel obstacle pour north stream 2 déjà
vu d'un mauvais oeil par les états unis
et une partie de l'europe qui craignent
la mainmise de gazprom en la matière sur
le vieux continent
le projet doit faire face à de nouvelles
pressions les doutes exprimés par
certains états quant à une éventuelle
implication des autorités russes dans la
sphère navalni pourrait avoir des
conséquences sur l'ambitieux chantier
une hypothèse que n'avait pas exclu
berlin dès la semaine dernière
owned by notre vif intérêt pour une
réponse européenne montre aussi
clairement que nous sommes ouverts à
toutes les options de sanctions
toutefois je voudrais souligner une fois
de plus que le nord stream 2 n'est pas
seulement un projet allemand
une centaine d'entreprises de 12 pays
européens sont concernés
cela aussi doit être inclus dans les
considérations nous ne devrions pas
permettre la bi latéralisation du
conflit c'est une réponse européenne
commune dont il s'agit ici d'un gel des
travaux constituerait un coup d'arrêt
pour le gazoduc qui doit relier la
russie à l'allemagne
en complément de north stream 1
opérationnel depuis 2012
mais pour le président écologiste de
l'autriche il n'est pas judicieux de
mélanger la sphère navalni et nord
stream 2 moi personnellement je ne vois
aucun lien entre le cas navalni et nord
stream 2 nord stream 2 constitue pour
moi un projet commercial qui concerne la
russie l'ukraine et des partenaires
européens
c'est une question commerciale entre des
partenaires qui coopère depuis plusieurs
décennies
pour conclure je tiens à ajouter que
cette question politico économique doit
être réglé en europe et non à washington
si l'allemagne affirme avoir trouvé des
traces de nos vies chuck dans
l'organisme d'alex et navalni la russie
a toujours nié être responsable de son
état de santé